les retraites c'est quelque chose que
d'arrêt de tout le monde
ça concerne naturellement celles et ceux
qui vont bientôt prendre leur retraite
ça concerne les nouvelles génération les
jeunes et le débat normalement au
Parlement le rendu avoir lieu dans les
conditions mais sont-ils ou la
démocratie soit au rendez-vous où on a
les projets contre le projet argument
contre arguments et en fait on assiste à
quoi à blocage fou de la part de la nups
sur les 15000 12500 qui leur
appartiennent ça veut dire qu'ils sont
venus avec une stratégie de blocage mais
on sait dorénavant pourquoi ils sont
venus avec cette stratégie ils voulaient
surtout pas qu'ils arrivions au fameux
articles 7 qui va prévoir d'augmenter
l'âge des départs à la retraite il ne
voulait pas d'ailleurs parce que le
guide suprême Jean-Luc Mélenchon leur
intime et l'ordre il y a sur un tweet
donc maintenant ça y est ils sont
démasqués et c'est d'autant plus dommage
que c'est très forme elle permettait
notamment sur les carrières hachées ou
le groupe démocrates c'est beaucoup
battu pour les femmes les cari arrachées
concernent les femmes les femmes qui ont
eu malheureusement dans leur vie des
fois des périodes d'interruption du
travail pour des licenciements pour nous
a dit ou pour simplement s'occuper de
leurs enfants ou de leurs parents et
bien ce cas hiérarchie il y a des vraies
avancées sur les petites retraites elle
est vraies avancées sur les femmes dont
les congés maternités pour les enfants
nés avant 2012 n'était pas intégré ils
le seront dorénavant grâce à nous et ça
va se traduire par plusieurs dizaines
d'euros mensuels pour ces femmes dans
leur retraite la suite d'abord c'est que
le modèle est donc les groupes
démocrates a mis son empreinte dans ce
texte une clause de revoyure donc en
clair voir en 2027 ou en est cette
réforme qu'est-ce qui a marché qu'est-ce
qui a pas marché quels sont les progrès
que nous avons fait par rapport au début
pour sécuriser les financements de ce
régime par répartition deuxième chose un
manquement qui est porté par notamment
notre ami avec Christophe Blanchet
concernant on le sait nos seniors et
pour ce qu'on appelle les taux d'action
du travail nous avons eu satisfaction
hier un amendement que je porte le nom
du groupe avec Jean-Paul Mathis sur les
femmes et qui sera naturellement intégré
dans le texte et maintenant on va aller
au Sénat si on avait dû examiner
l'intégralité des amendements il fallait
encore ouvrir peut-être qu'un jour trois
semaines je ne sais pas
avez vu que les stratégie des différents
groupes de l'IPS est différent qui
communiste on retire énormément hier
soir la nuit pêche venait passer un par
un voyez là cet après-midi nous avons
1100 amendements qui sont
identiques les Françaises et les
Français doivent savoir que on a ce
qu'on appelle des tunnels d'ailleurs on
vient d'inventer le tunnel sous la
Manche le plus long c'est un tunnel
lequel il y a 1100 amendements